when a crypto exchange is hacked for 200
million dollars people understandably
want answers how did it happen can it be
prevented in the future and if you steal
200 million dollars how do you ever
spend all that money isn't crypto
traceable on the blockchain well today
we're going to answer those questions
welcome to a coffee zilla christmas day
10. we were going to do a silly video
about shark tank but since bitmark got
hacked over the last few days for 200
million i thought our time was better
spent perhaps educating people about
what happens when 200 million dollars
goes missing i mean that's a lot of
money with 200 million dollars you could
buy like 10 10 million dollar studios
maybe even 20 if you knew the right
people so these are no joke numbers here
the hack happened december 4th 2021
we'll bring down the board here um it
happened to bitmark which is a crypto
exchange and it was first noticed by
peckshield inc on twitter they posted
hot wallet compromise and then linked to
a bunch of shady transactions out of
bitmart now for those who don't know
every exchange has two types of wallets
you have cold wallets and hot wallets
cold wallets are offline and used for
crypto storage while hot wallets are
used for everyday use and they're
connected to the internet it's important
to know that hot wallets are more
vulnerable to attack now first bitmart
was denying that there was a hack they
say i repeatedly confirmed to you there
was no hack did it get hacked no sir but
it didn't take long for the bitmart ceo
to confirm there was a hack and
initially he estimated that the losses
were about 150 million dollars this
estimate would later rise to 200 million
dollars now at the same time they also
paused withdrawals probably to prevent a
run on the accounts and so now that
there's been a confirmed hack now what
well it's a race between the hacker and
bitmart in an event like this there are
goals for each party on the one hand you
have the crypto exchange who wants to
limit the damage done by making those
stolen crypto assets hard to cash out
and this is done by all the crypto
exchanges working together to flag
stolen crypto and prevent these assets
from being converted to fiat aka us
dollars or euros and this is why
whenever someone's hacked you'll see a
tweet like this we will do our best to
assist bitmart in the handling of this
issue if there are any inflows of
related assets we will report and assist
in a timely manner you see these crypto
exchanges have an incentive to team up
and sort of protect each other protect
the herd the idea being that if a hacker
can never spin the money it will
discourage hacks of other crypto
exchanges and encouraged the hacker to
return the funds as happened with the
poly network hack if you remember that
hacker gave back more than 600 million
dollars in stolen crypto in part due to
the difficulty of moving those funds now
on the other hand obviously you also
have the hacker who has much different
goals they want to offload those stolen
assets as soon as possible and hide
those 200 million dollars get it off
their bucks and how do they do that
because i guess the obvious question is
isn't crypto completely transparent and
traceable well yes and no while it's
true that every transaction on the
blockchain is captured and traceable
there's some tricky ways you can hide
where the money is going and coming from
enter tornado cache see tornado cash is
the answer of how to hide where your
money is going i'll explain how it works
in a simplified way to make this really
easy imagine you're trying to track
dollar bills and so you mark them with a
big x on the front of the bill and so
now you can trace them anywhere in the
world you might think that that would
stop anyone from spending that money
because now you can just trace them
around the world but what tornado cash
does messes that up imagine tornado cash
as one of these one of these money
mixing machines you see on tv that blows
up all the money into the air and
creates literally a sort of a tornado of
money how it works how tornado cash
works is you go into tornado cash and
you go ahead and you throw a bill in
there let's say you give a dollar to
tornado cash they will give you an iou
with a special code for it so later you
can come back to the machine and redeem
it for exactly one dollar at that point
what tornado cash wants you to do after
putting your money in is just wait as
other people use their service why well
let's say i'm bitmart or law enforcement
i can see that one dollar goes into here
into tornado cash and so i'm looking for
anyone withdrawing one dollar at the
same time right well here's the problem
the longer the person waits to withdraw
the more people use this machine and
withdraw a dollar ten dollars twenty
dollars the more we don't know who is
who and maybe after a day a month a year
the hacker comes back to this machine
takes their dollar out and puts it into
a new unassociated wallet well at that
point maybe 10 000 people have come by
and done the same thing the question is
how do you track that fortunately the
answer is you kind of can't now
obviously trying to launder 200 million
dollars is much different from washing
one dollar you got to wait a lot longer
you got to space out those withdrawals
you got to withdraw to a bunch of
different wallets not just one wallet
but the principles are the same and so
obviously this is a huge problem now is
it tornado cash's fault they would say
no they would say millions of users use
the platform legally and they just don't
ask questions about where the money
comes from but i don't think many people
will find that answer acceptable
especially not governments although it
may not matter because since tornado
cash is a decentralized protocol you
can't shut it down easily even the
creators might not be able to shut it
down and this is exactly why for a lot
of criminals tornado cash is their
favorite way for laundering money it's
quite frankly stupidly simple to do as
sad of a sentence as that is and going
back to the bitmart hack that's exactly
what this hacker did as you can see from
the graphic after bitmark got hacked the
hacker got a bunch of ethereum and a
bunch of tokens they exchanged the
tokens for ethereum they sent the
ethereum over here and then they
transferred it to tornado cash at which
point you're kind of out of luck
this is the dark side of crypto that
many people rarely confront crypto is an
amazing tool there are a lot of awesome
innovations happening but one of the
downsides is that criminal operations
are much better able to monetize and
move money around and that is something
that needs to be addressed if
governments are going to accept it now
as for the reason for this hack two days
later the cause would be labeled a
stolen private key but they didn't
clarify if that means a rogue employee
or that they had emails hacked either
way sheldon the ceo said that bitmart
would cover the losses out of their own
pocket obviously this is just trying to
soothe investors fears and time will
tell if it works but either way it
raises interesting questions about the
implications of decentralized finance
protocols they're powerful tools but the
knife cuts both ways whatever they
enable regular people to do they often
enable criminals to do and how
regulators will end up dealing with them
will be interesting to follow either way
i hope you learned something from this
breakdown of the bitmart hack how it
happened where the money went and
whether i think it's likely that the
funds will be recovered i do not anyway
thanks for watching pump the stock let's
get to a million to save the kids hope
you learned something see you in the
next one
[Music]
you pan okay